every year our planet makes one full
trip around the Sun and while that means
we're already moving at Breakneck speeds
we're about to ramp that speed up
like way up let's turn the earth into a
planet-sized spaceship and crank it up
to light speed
why would this make earth extremely
heavy
what would happen to Earth if it started
orbiting so fast
and what would it be like to experience
all this from down on the ground
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth orbited the Sun at
the speed of light
okay nothing travels faster than light
so brace yourself because light moves
through space at a blistering 300
000 kilometers per second
that means from the moment a particle of
light leaves the sun hurtling directly
toward you on Earth it takes just eight
minutes before it hits you in the face
or gently caresses your face
yeah it only takes light eight minutes
to travel
150 million kilometers and light
reflecting off the moon only needs one
second to reach your eyes
now when it comes to an object cranking
up to the speed of light things aren't
just as simple as picking up the pace
let's take our planet as it gets closer
to the speed of light its mass increases
until it becomes infinite
and to move an infinitely massive object
you're gonna need an infinite amount of
energy
and that's just impossible until now
Earth already orbits the Sun at 30
kilometers per second
and while that's not slow at all compare
it to the speed of light and it's not
even a drop in the bucket if you want to
be more precise Earth orbits this big
scorching ball at only 0.01 of the speed
of light
so we've got a lot of ground to cover
here
but don't get ahead of yourself because
even if we just increased Earth's
orbital velocity to 42 kilometers per
second we'd be in serious Danger
that's because at this speed Earth would
achieve its orbital escape velocity that
means it would be traveling fast enough
to escape the sun's gravitational pull
we'd just be traveling out into space
another cold Rogue planet with no star
system to call home
of course we'd cross the solar system
before being ejected out of it for good
after about three years of moving at
this speed Earth would reach Neptune at
that point we'd have already passed all
the other planets in the outer solar
system if we got really unlucky Earth
might crash into the big ball of gas
Jupiter along the way
now for a moment that would be a pretty
view as we approached but what a shame
it wouldn't last long enough for you to
enjoy because Earth colliding with
Jupiter would have some lethal side
effects
but we wouldn't let your Epic Journey
end so abruptly in this scenario Earth
would keep hurtling through the solar
system and beyond
we'd keep speeding further and further
out of our planetary Hometown and into
the big unknown
and without the sun's heat well Earth
would slowly but surely become a cold
and lifeless Rock
okay well that didn't go as planned at
all so how about we start over
let's break the laws of physics and keep
our planet in the sun's orbit as it
reaches light speed
what would that be like
well to accelerate the entire planet to
such an incredible speed we'd need a lot
of energy
how much well more than you could
imagine
even if you wanted to accelerate
yourself to only about 90 percent of the
speed of light well you'd need as much
energy as the entire world consumes in
five days
so where in the universe would we manage
to get enough energy to speed the whole
planet up
well your best bet would be to follow
the lead of a very rare but extremely
fast kind of star a hyper velocity star
these are stars that can reach speeds of
up to 33 percent of the speed of light
there may be as few as 1 000 of these
kinds of stars in our entire galaxy
all because they need a unique chain of
events to unfold first
hyper velocity Stars reach their hyper
speeds by orbiting a black hole that's
colliding with another black hole these
two black holes begin a kind of dance
with each other spinning faster and
faster until eventually they let go and
that gravitational disruption leads to
the Stars being ejected Across the
Universe at these insane speeds
all right so it's simple in order for us
to reach the speed of light we just need
to swing around a black hole or two
what's the worst that could happen there
now experiencing light speed on Earth
wouldn't be exactly like what you see in
the movies
when the Millennium Falcon or the USS
Enterprise engage thrusters
for starters you wouldn't see any more
stars in the night sky
that's because you'd be experiencing
what's known as the Doppler effect in
scientific terms all the light traveling
toward Earth would now have a higher
frequency moving from the visible
spectrum into the X-ray range
to put it simply the light from the
Stars would become invisible to you
because the human eye can't see x-rays
[Music]
and it could mean invisible danger for
you
x-rays can cause many health problems
and increase your risk of cancer while
today's atmosphere is thick enough to
prevent most of this radiation from
Stars reaching us traveling at the speed
of light might put our atmosphere to the
test
yeah we could lose our protective air
Shield which also means on this Earth
that you wouldn't be able to breathe
but even if our atmosphere somehow
stayed in place traveling at light speed
would quickly damage it even something
as small as a hydrogen molecule would
become an incredible hazard
slamming into our atmosphere at such
high velocities it could cook it into
Oblivion
and I'm not sure you'd enjoy being on
Earth if it suddenly lost its atmosphere
but that's a story
for another what if